have you ever seen a photo of a planet
made entirely of living flesh
or an insect human hybrid that can
control minds or a thousand foot long
sea serpent that emerges in Iceland
every year
these images might look like they come
from some long-lost paranormal case File
but this is actually the work of the
brilliant artist and World Builder
Eduardo Valdez Evia who has spent the
last several years bringing to life a
menagerie of nightmares so detailed that
I had to know more
so what would you say inspires your art
I'm a really big fan of the found
footage genre the type of horror that is
not presented directly as if you're the
subject or you're being chased by this
monster you've just found the Diary of a
person that was chased by that monster
and you are living that experience
through those documents
brought to life through a combination of
old photographs in new elements Valdez
evia's art merges history and The
Surreal with images that feel like they
come directly from classified historical
documents the artists create Standalone
images as well as richly detailed series
with dense interconnected lore so for
this entry into the archive we'll
investigate the monsters and Madness of
these dark case files and you can
support the artist on patreon and follow
the projects using the links in the
description now prepare yourself for the
Terrors of Valdez Evia
foreign
's longest project is the megalomorphous
series a fragmented Anthology exploring
Humanity's many unfortunate encounters
with mysterious insect-like life forms
what inspired the megalomorpha project I
kind of modeled this story after
internet rabbit holes though it's a
bunch of small stories in each of these
stories there's like one piece of the
puzzle of that larger lore but only one
you need to read a bunch of them to
start putting them together
one of the earliest fragments of the
megalomorphous story comes from 1910 on
the coast of Maine an unidentified
carcass washes up on shore a strange
shell that resembles a giant insect
shortly after the town's fishermen who
discover it become paranoid that the
abnormal life form is cursed and burned
the remains before scientists can
examine them
another sighting comes in 1913 when the
Australian Antarctic expedition finds
something strange in the ice recovered
diary entries indicate that the crew
extracted the Frozen life form from the
glacier and brought it back to Camp
unfortunately the specimen would be lost
later that winter when crewman Sydney
Jeffries came to believe the creature
was trapped and wanted him to break it
free in the end he shattered the Frozen
block with an ax destroying the specimen
Within
the megalomorphat they can kind of make
themselves appear to the people around
them as kind of whatever they interpret
and it's based on their previous beliefs
what their background is they may think
it's some sort of deity
a recovered poster shows that a few
years later in the 1920s the Turner Bros
circus began touring the USA with an
unusual exhibit they claimed it was a
species of Amazonian Mammoth ant
although no such genus exists one of the
two founders of the circus allegedly
became obsessed with the mysterious
insect and began sleeping in the cage
with it eventually he escaped with the
ant never to be seen again
a leaked report tells us nearly a
century later in June of 1961. a group
of Russian Navy personnel discovered
something unsettling in the Cara sea
upon investigating a sunken merchant
ship a diver Came Upon the nest of some
sort of creature analysis of the eggs
determined they belonged to a species
previously unknown to science but while
the diver's camera was recovered the
diver was not the rest of the crew
deemed the waters unsafe to investigate
further in what eventually became of the
site remains a mystery
researcher Nigel Buckley Tracked Down
the details for most of the
megalomorphous sightings making it his
life's work to collect the scattered
reports on the creatures before passing
away in 1986. fragments of notes and
illustrations indicate Buckley believed
the life forms were related to Insects
despite the megalomorphos extreme
variability in appearance Buckley
theorized they were a single species
that went through radical metamorphosis
over their life cycle while Buckley
could not prove the existence of these
nightmares the sightings continued after
his death but we'll come back to the
megalomorpha
another brilliant horror series is the
facade a paranoia-inducing work that
comes from a collaboration between
Valdez Evia and fellow artist Luke Baker
and love Luke's art so we're chatting
one day and I was like we should collab
on something quick converged on the
topic of doppelgangers
The Story begins in 1865. a photographer
Reveals His latest invention to the
French Emperor's Court the Turning
portrait yet the portrait of one Baron
Renard comes out wrong the camera is
deemed effective unbeknownst to the
court the real problem is that the
individual in the photograph isn't
actually Renard
the next sighting of this life form
known as the facade comes in 1896 when
during the X-ray craze people buy
machines to show to party guests in one
such event financier Franz Mayfield has
this plate taken revealing him to be the
facade he keeps the print a secret until
Vanishing years later
decades pass without sightings until
1960 when a six-year-old from Chicago is
admitted to the Lurie Children's
Hospital in a crayon drawing she claims
there is a monster pretending to be her
mother her records show another
breakdown at age 23 thought to be the
time when the facade chose a new victim
it changes identities every time it's
found out it'll I go out kill someone
else and become them
the last sighting comes in 1977 when a
bystander reports to the Chicago PD that
he saw a man with a shifting face
swallow someone whole his story wasn't
believed although a single police sketch
was made of the suspect the report was
not investigated and the facade's
current location remains unknown
many of Valdez evia's most striking
pieces don't belong to a series but our
Standalone works like this photograph of
a group of people watching the emergence
of the nidhog the whole idea is that
this huge creature the nidhog every year
explodes from the ground but I want to
set it into a world where it's a
completely normal thing and everybody's
used to it the name nidhog comes from
Norse mythology and belongs to a dragon
that gnaws at the roots of the world
tree yet the people in these images
don't Revere the nidhog as something
Mythic but rather a spectacle to be
gawked at which feels strangely
realistic
taking hoaxes and pieces of folklore and
turning them into something more
realistic is a motif that appears
frequently throughout Valdes evia's art
for example Jenny Hanover's or hoaxes
created by taking the dried carcass of
array and fashioning it into a fanciful
creature to sell to tourists yet one
piece by Valdez Evia imagines a deep sea
submarine capturing a live specimen on
camera revealing an uncanny and
human-like life form staring back from
the dark abyss it's impressive how the
art turns a rather ridiculous piece of
folklore into something actually fear
provoking
in Valdez Evia isn't afraid to embrace
absurdity and horror at the same time
one of my favorite pieces shows a trail
camera catching something strange on the
25th of December 2020. the following
Christmas the owner of the camera hears
a horrible cracking sound like breaking
bones coming from their fireplace
figuring migratory Birds had made a nest
inside they take a picture up the
chimney the creepy and the funny is
really easy to mix together I like doing
both
one of the best combinations of creepy
and funny comes from the crab person
images a project in which volunteers
test subjects undergo a procedure
intended to evolve their human body
plans into something more advanced with
unexpected results a mad scientists
tried to speed up Evolution just to see
how what mankind would evolve into and
oh no I'd evolve into crabs
this series is a play on carsonization
or the tendency of crustaceans to evolve
into crabs an amusing natural phenomenon
I've discussed before on the channel so
perhaps the ultimate human would also
have a defensive ribcage shell and a
keratinous claw
foreign of course some of Valdez evia's
work is more overtly terrifying
returning to the fragmented
megalomorphous series the next glimpse
of the giant insect's influence comes in
Norway in
1953. here an isolated church becomes a
strange cult worshiping a mysterious
being journalist erlang Jorgensen is
allowed to visit the community and take
pictures although he is not permitted to
enter the church during sermon hours
according to erling's notes however on
the day of his departure he is overtaken
by curiosity sneaking into the church he
sees an immense moth-like creature
appear on the wall the congregation is
silent as the Monstrous insect pulsates
seemingly under its control in my
megalomorpha series it's all about these
giant insects kind of manipulating
people and kind of brainwashing them
this one that specializes in releasing
pheromones with this huge organ could
brainwash a whole group of people
after the sermon ends a fire destroys
the church and the insect that day it is
only years later upon erling's death
that it is revealed that he is the one
who lit the match
but the story of the megalomorpha
doesn't end there more recent
discoveries in fact suggest that the
creatures may have been appearing for
centuries in 1982 a local news channel
in Sicily discovers something bizarre on
the wall of a Roman ruin a mosaic
depicts what looks like an enormous wasp
eating an antelope the piece stands out
from the other realistic scenes and does
not seem to match any known Roman myths
in a medieval codex from 15th century
Spain the megalomorpha seems to appear
again while traveling in a boat a
nobleman's son discovers an unusual
cocoon in the sea which soon begins to
alter his mind when an insect hatches
from the Cocoon the nobleman's son
believes the creature to be holy and has
numerous statues made in its honor all
of which have bug-like features
but other pieces indicate that human
interactions with the megalomorpha go
back much further Neolithic paintings in
a cave found near tiering Spain depict
what appears to be people fighting a
large six-legged insect in the next
image however people kneel before a
similar figure in a more solemn pose
they appear to be making offerings to it
The Following part seems to depict the
next stage in the insect's life cycle
but it has been purposefully chiseled
off leaving few recognizable traces the
final scene shows more people kneeling
and laying down their weapons below
beings that show elements of both human
and the previous six-limbed creatures an
image that is perhaps the most
unsettling of all near the paintings is
a human skull with unknown malformations
taken as a whole it seems like the
megalomorphous life cycle eventually
involves merging with human hosts but
we'll come back to that story
across Valdez evia's gallery of Terrors
another ingeniously bizarre concept is
zippet totec a planet seemingly made of
living flesh that passes close to Earth
there's something cosmically terrifying
and strangely amusing about this visual
with veins crisscrossing the planet like
rivers in spots that resemble eyes where
craters should be
so what can you tell us about the planet
made of living flesh it does have a
little bit of you know speculative
biology stuff as accurate you can get
about meat planets it looks red and
meaty and that is because it uses a
pigment kind of like chlorophyll to
absorb energy from stars and to move
around it next to you know expels to
matter kind of like fought around the
universe in a way
in the story that accompanies these
images after passing close to Earth the
zippay totec leaves behind fragments
torn from its surface due to Earth's
gravitational pull authorities warn
people not to touch the debris as it
still seems to pulse with life which
doesn't bode well
and after the planet leaves the solar
system the probe Voyager 2 takes a space
photo of what appears to be another
member of zippetotek species that is now
just a skeleton so the bone version of
the meat planet that we see it was one
of these planets that didn't make it it
was very unlucky and it didn't find a
new star system and it kept roaming
around until you know it's just the husk
one of Valdez evia's longest series is
the lycanthrope project an exploration
of an alternate history with werewolves
made in collaboration with The Talented
horror artist David Romero the mixed
media series brilliantly reimagines The
Werewolf Mythos reframing the monster's
relationship to society in unexpected
ways
so what was the vision behind the
lycanthrope project one of the driving
Concepts we had behind this was putting
the the werewolf where the vampire
usually is so the vampire usually works
as this aristocratic killer it's the
it's the personification of the noble
man kind of leeching off the you know
regular people and removing the the
vampire from there and putting a
werewolf which is usually is more like
be seal thing it's not usually a
creature that's in control
[Music]
one of the earliest depictions of
werewolves in the lycanthrope project
comes from a Roman Mosaic which depicts
a party of hunters killing a lycanthrope
the curse of the wolf is passed on
through Bloodlines and although in this
image the werewolves are hunted Powers
soon shift as individuals with the curse
rise through the ranks of nobility the
next image depiction comes from a
medieval triptych commissioned in the
12th century by a secret society of
knights called the order of the new moon
this group of werewolves which features
heavily in the lycanthrope project
believe themselves to be a chosen holy
people destined to rule over the masses
inching closer to the present an old
photograph shows how in some insular
Nordic communities old customs of
worshiping lycanthropes are still
maintained in ancient times these groups
practiced initiation rights that often
included wearing masks shaped like wolf
heads showing how the influence of
werewolves has spread across the globe
in time the ranks of the secretive order
of the new moon open to a select few at
the dawn of the 20th century powerful
figures begin intermarrying into the
family lured by the promise of joining
the like and bloodline
today the higher ranks of the enigmatic
order are said to be formed by the rich
and Powerful from across the world the
full extent of their reach however is
left a mystery like many of Valdez
evia's projects The Narrative is
intentionally open-ended encouraging the
viewer to fill in the gaps
and to conclude or look into the mind of
Valdez Evia will return one final time
to the Terrors of the megalomorpha
project some of the most Illuminating
fragments of the narrative or the last
surviving photographs from the secretive
De La Cruz family which at last offer us
a look at a megalomorpha human hybrid
according to Adrian De La Cruz a
disowned relative who smuggled the
photographs out of the Family Estate the
monster in this image was known to the
family as Tio Alfredo Adrian claims the
creature has always been there since the
time of his great-grandfathers having
convinced their minds it was part of the
family
so how did you approach designing the
megalomorpha human hybrid it took me a
long time to kind of figure out how to
mix those bug and human elements it's
carrying the bones outside the human
part of it is kind of out in the
exoskeleton
according to the account of Adrian De La
Cruz he planned to bring an end to the
creature by drinking a bottle of Cyanide
and letting it feed upon him it is
unclear if he was successful
in any case the tale of the megalomorpha
continues into the modern era in 2004 a
company charting the sea floor off the
coast of Hawaii discovers an abandoned
remotely operated vehicle the vehicle
was lost during a survey of a sunken
ship with its umbilical cord cut off and
on the vehicle's camera is a photo of a
familiar insect-like creature which
seems to have been the cause of the
vehicle's disappearance and perhaps the
wreck of the ship itself
the final glimpse of the megalomorpha
comes in the form of trail cam pictures
from 2006 recovered from a now defunct
online hunting form as for what happened
to the megalomorpha from here however is
anyone's guess for who can say what
lurks in the dark corners of the world
this brief glimpse into the Striking in
surreal creations of Eduardo Valdez Evia
leaves many questions still unanswered
but according to the artist himself a
mystery is most engaging when there's a
little ambiguity I'm not one for giving
out the whole lore to everybody because
I think that ruins a little bit of the
fun it's that found horror thing where
it makes you like dig for more you're
kind of cursing yourself with knowledge
but you need to know more
if you'd like to discover more of this
mysterious art for yourself there are
links in the description a tremendous
thank you to Eduardo Valdes Evia for
sharing insights into his many projects
once again you can support him on
patreon and follow him on social media
using the links down below
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
foreign